now as the Mega Millions grows to Mega
billions many people are gambling on
their luck in hopes of winning big but
customers say they won't be gambling
when it comes to financial decisions if
they ever do win the lottery Mary Jane
billiesza takes us to the lotto store at
Prim with how people plan to secure
those winnings
the line is steadily moving here at the
lotto store in Prim where people tell me
they'll happily wait in line no matter
how long it takes at a chance to win the
lucky jackpot I'm a saver so I'm gonna
invest and let it multiply and create
generational wealth for generations to
come LaShawn Hughes drove down here with
her husband and friend from Las Vegas
she plans to donate her money to several
Charities as well as invest her money to
prevent debt and bankruptcy as some
lottery winners declared in the past
they usually go broke in five years you
did your research I sure have I plan not
to be a statistic I want to keep it and
have it go for Generations buy a few
properties invest and let the money
accrue interest make money grandkids
grandkids yeah we have ten so we got to
make sure we're they're taken care of
Las Vegas local Tim McCoy agrees you
hear the horror stories too the people
that you know they win it and they're
broke six months later or two years
later or whatever just like Hughes McCoy
is being practical he says if he ever
won it big he would just buy a new car
and a house I expected to see a huge
line when I got down here I was going to
drive to California I just figured I'd
pull off and see if there was you know
what kind of line was or was it one on a
billion chances of winning so
you don't count your chickens for the
you know your eggs for the chickens